the media lament president Trump's
cruelty everything is racist and
Democrats look to the future I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
myriad and sundry topics for us to cover
today at veritable cornucopia of issues
and commentary coming your way in just a
second but first I want to remind you
that we are actually taking the Ben
Shapiro show live this month to
audiences in Dallas and Phoenix what's
crazy is that we are now less than two
weeks away from these events each venue
is almost entirely sold out thousands of
tickets sold if you have not yet gotten
your ticket go to Live Nation calm or
Ticketmaster calm and search Ben Shapiro
you don't want to miss the event it's
really give me a lot of fun I can't wait
to see you there it's going to be just a
blast it's gonna be awesome
also I want to remind you about your
Second Amendment rights because the
clock is ticking how would you like to
hit the range tomorrow with a brand new
gun well I would and the US ECA wants to
make that dream come true they are here
to help train and protect responsible
gun owners like you and me and right now
they are giving away free guns every day
so you got to go check them out they're
giving away a different gun every single
day it all ends soon just go to defend
your family now dot-com to get entered
right now it could get up to 17 chances
to win your gun daily it could be 17
kimber 17 Glocks 17 new cigs all you
have to do is go to defend your family
now dot-com to reveal which gun you
could be taking home today
it all ends soon again today's gun
disappears at midnight tonight so don't
put it off don't miss your chance you
could win a new gun every single day
defend your family defend your family
now.com for your free country to win
right now again defend your family now
calm you Seca does amazing work they not
only provide you the educational
resources that you need they also will
provide you the legal help they need in
case god forbid you extra have to fire a
gun at anybody so go check them out
right now defend your family now calm
again defend your family now calm for a
chance to win a gun defend your family
now calm us you see a great organization
all right so we begin today with the
update on the alex jones banning so alex
jones is as i have said about 1 million
times at this point an insane person
alex jones is the guy who says that the
government is attempting to turn the
frogs gay he is a person who believes
that the Sandy Hook shooting was
actually a false flag and that the dead
kids were actually child actors or at
least that's something he expressed on
his show he suggested the same thing
about various other terrorist attacks he
suggested that the Syrian gas attack by
the Syrian government was actually
performed by the white helmets he says
crazy borderline libelous and slanderous
things on a routine basis he said a
couple of weeks ago that Robert Muller
was forwarding child rape
some suction and that he wanted to get
in a duel with Robert Muller now his
supporters will say that all of this is
just shock value entertainment kind of
stuff whatever it is it's garbage but
does that mean that Facebook and YouTube
and Apple and all of these various
social media platforms ought to ban his
material well not really on the basis on
which they are claiming if they wanted
to say listen we're gonna ban slanderous
material libelous material we're gonna
ban material that incites violence then
that at least is a workable standard but
instead all of these social media groups
said that they're going to use hate
speech regulations essentially to ban
Alex Jones and as I said yesterday on
the program hate speech is a really
really vague term when you say hate
speech over and over and over and then
you apply it to a bunch of random people
and topics that you just disagree with
so I ben shapiro and participating in
hate speech when i refused to use your
preferred pronoun as a transgender
person and alex jones engaged in hate
speech when he says that children who
were murdered in a mass shooting attack
were actually child actors in a false
flag if you're going to equate those two
things then hate speech has no actual
meaning and this is the problem the left
actually want hate speech to have no
actual meaning except for stuff they
don't like and the proof is in the
pudding the stuff that they want a ban
is invariably stuff that is anti left I
don't think Alex Jones is a conservative
in any serious way I don't think that
he's even on the right in any serious
way he believes in bigger government and
variety of issues he is more a
provocateur and an anti left activist
there is a difference between
conservatism and being anti left the
Nazis were anti left they weren't
actually American conservatives there
are a lot of folks who are anti left who
are not actually American conservatives
American conservatism is a very specific
brand about limited government and
god-given rights with that said Alex
Jones is being targeted by the left
because he doesn't like the left very
much even though he has some kind of
common principles with them in terms of
the size and scope of government well
the left is suggesting that social media
ought to use Alex Jones to get a foot in
the door there's a CNN article today all
about how CNN had basically pressured
social media into banning Alex Jones you
remember just a couple of weeks ago
Facebook came out they said listen we're
not gonna throw Alex Jones off the
platform and then just this week they
said well you know maybe we'll do that
after all the problem is that once
politicians and folks on the Left get
their foot in the door once they feel
that they have the leverage to knock out
anybody
they don't like under the rubric of hate
speech you can fairly well guarantee
that that is exactly what they are going
to do case in point
Chris Murphy's senator from Connecticut
so he tweets out last night Infowars
which is Alex Jones's execrable outlet
is the tip of a giant iceberg of hate
and lies that uses sites like Facebook
and YouTube to tear our nation apart
these companies must do more than take
down one web site the survival of our
democracy depends on it so this is Chris
Murphy in actual elected government
official who is now calling on private
companies to crack down on speech that
he does not like that's all this is he
is not suggesting any sort of principle
that has any limits to it he is not
suggesting slander and libel be the
rules he is not suggesting that violence
be the rule he is suggesting that
anything he doesn't like anybody who he
labels lying should be banned by
Facebook and YouTube what's hilarious
about this is that the entire left which
has suggested the President Trump is
awful awful awful awful for shouting
fake news at CNN these same people who
shout fake news at any outlet they don't
like they say that they should be able
to push private institutions into
banning speech so my question of Chris
Murphy was okay
Facebook's a private institution can do
it once YouTube is a private institution
it can do it it wants but you are a
congress person right you are a member
of the Senate of the United States you
do not have the governmental power under
the First Amendment to make a law
abridging freedom of speech so what
you're gonna do about it
you're gonna try and regulate Facebook
and YouTube you're gonna try and call
them a monopoly and then break them up
you're gonna try and nationalize social
media sites because you actually the
government wants to control what people
can and cannot say the fact is that even
if the government owned a site like
Facebook or YouTube they would not be
allowed to engage in any sort of content
content discrimination they would not
allow they under the First Amendment
government sources are not allowed to
engage in content-based discrimination
and content-based bias but the idea here
really is the Democrats are going to
punish all of these companies for not
doing what they want they're gonna
punish Facebook they're gonna punish
YouTube and that's the reason you've
seen Facebook and YouTube respond so
over in in such over-the-top fashion to
all of the Democratic complaints about
fake news on their platforms and we
talked about this a few months ago when
Mark Zuckerberg was called idiotically
to the floor of the Senate to answer
questions about Russian hacking and
Russian interference in the election
Democrats have been saying people like
Dianne Feinstein had been saying while
the Russians really affected the
election with Facebook now the evidence
that the Russians affected the election
of Facebook is extraordinarily minimal I
mean I've seen the Senate documents on
this sort of stuff and what they
basically show is a bunch of crappy
Russian memes that are really poorly
done and we're seen by a minut number of
people I should know how the metrics
works we have one of the most active
Facebook pages in America the Ben
Shapiro Facebook page is extraordinarily
actively about four million followers
and we generate legitimately hundreds of
millions of clicks per year but the
Senate was suggesting that the entire
election turned the Democrats were
suggesting the entire election turned on
Russian fake news being distributed via
Facebook the reason they were making a
big issue out of this is because they
wanted to push Facebook into regulating
stuff they don't like and you're saying
Chris Murphy basically saying that
openly now again Facebook and YouTube
they have the capacity and the power and
the ability under the First Amendment to
do whatever they want their first and
there they are a private company but
once you get government officials
sounding off and suggesting that various
sites should be shut down in order to
quote unquote save democracy that's
burning the village in order to save it
once the government says you have to
shut down outlets in order to save
democracy you have to start thinking
about whether that is actually a
destruction of democracy in order to
quote unquote save democracy if you
think that America hangs on a knife's
edge because Infowars is out there then
I would suggest that perhaps you have
the wrong idea of what a republic is the
whole basis of a republic is that the
people are smart enough to see past the
stupidity of places like Infowars that
the vast majority of people are not
taken in by Alex Jones's shtick and the
fact is that if we're gonna get into the
business of banning companies that
routinely engage in fake news there a
bunch on the Left who we ought to be
looking at but we shouldn't get into
that business because it's a dangerous
business and this is why if Facebook and
YouTube want to go after Alex Jones on
the grounds that he is he is committing
certain acts that could theoretically
violate legal lines that is one thing
but if they want to set up this soft
standard that can then be manipulated by
the Democrats that is completely another
and it is astonishing to me that folks
on the Left don't see how this could be
turned on the other ear the same people
who are complaining that Trump calls the
media fake news these same people have
no problem with Facebook and YouTube
banning Infowars and again I'm not
saying that Infowars and CNN are on the
same level I know that's an unpopular
thing to say among conservatives but CNN
in four
are not on the same level CNN actually
does report the news and when they get
things wrong they get things wrong and
apologize for it generally speaking they
are biased in their approach to the news
that is the big flaw with CNN but if you
are just to look at the number of true
things that CNN says on a daily basis
versus the number of true things
Infowars says on a daily basis there is
no comparison CNN is not promulgating
the conspiracy theory that pizza gate is
real I'm not going to pretend CNN and
Alex Jones are exactly the same ilk
because I don't think that they are
however if we're going to get into the
business of policing speech it's hard to
see where you draw that line and why you
would draw that line in a way that
doesn't include Infowars but does
include CNN or does include dailykos but
doesn't include Infowars or it does
include huffington post but doesn't
include daily wire very difficult to see
limiting principles here and limiting
principles are the necessity of a legal
system if you're a lawyer what you're
looking for is a law that can be equally
applied across the board if the law is
just a tool of the powerful that's when
you start to have problems and right now
the law is becoming a tool of the
powerful who are attempting to club
companies like Facebook and YouTube into
line this is why even when conservatives
say they want to regulate Facebook and
YouTube and Steve Danon has said this I
think no that's it it's more dangerous
than it's worth and it violates First
Amendment principles you shouldn't be
regulating private companies just
because you don't like what the private
companies are doing there's a lot of
talk today about well you can never
launch a competitor to Facebook you can
never launch a competitor to YouTube
why not Facebook started as a competitor
to MySpace are you saying that we can
never create a competitor to a company
that was founded in what 2007 I'm old
enough to remember one Yahoo was the
dominant search engine and then Google
took over I'm old enough to remember
when Alta Vista was the dominant search
engine before Yahoo so company there's
this weird idea that pervades America
that companies that are very powerful
today we're always powerful and always
will be powerful the reality is the
companies drop in and out of the stock
market and off the top 100 on a regular
basis the number of really long-lasting
companies in the United States without
government subsidies is actually pretty
low there's pretty high turnover in
business which is to say if Facebook
continues to be bad in its business
there will be a competitor that is
launched if YouTube continues to ban ad
revenue for a variety of various content
creators there will be alternative
sources that are created that are not
YouTube so there is a
solution tube material you don't like on
YouTube or Facebook and that is don't
watch it it does not push Facebook and
YouTube to ban all of that sort of
material now to talk about another
idiotic attempt to cram down government
in just one second but first let's talk
about your bathroom habits well let's
talk mostly about whether you shave or
whether you take a shower or whether you
do all the things that make you a human
being well if you do any of those things
what you actually need is Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave Club has everything
you need to get ready in the bathroom
any particular product that you want
they've got okay Dollar Shave Club has
got my favorite the coaming body
cleanser it's fantastic it's Evan its
amber and lavender scented I get out of
the shower my wife's like wow that
smells really good I'm like thank you
darling that's me well that's actually
not me that's the coaming body cleanser
from Dollar Shave Club go check it out
right now they've got a champ ooh
conditioner body while shoot paste hair
gel even a wipe that leaves your butt
feeling tingly clean all Dollar Shave
Club products are made with top-shelf
ingredients that will not break your
budget you will feel the difference plus
shipping is included with your
membership and here's a great way to try
Dollar Shave Club stuff for just 5 bucks
you can get their daily essentials
starter set it comes with body cleanser
one wipe Charlies that's the amazing
about wipe the world-famous shea butter
and their best razor that six blade
executive and then you can keep the
blades coming for a few bucks more per
month add in shampoo toothpaste anything
else you need for the bathroom check it
all out at dollarshaveclub.com slash
been there's a reason they're one of the
fastest growing companies in the country
because their stuff is awesome
dollarshaveclub.com slash men again
dollarshaveclub.com slash men go check
them out alright so speaking of leftist
attempts to involve government in areas
where it shouldn't be involved I have to
bring up this tweet that was shown to me
by our very own send you a full credit
to Sonya for spotting this idiocy Dylan
Matthews over at voxcom the font of much
of America's stupidity I would say that
Vox has more impact on America's stupid
then Infowars does because Vox actually
purports to be a non conspiratorial
website that just prints dumb crap on
regular basis and this is not to say
that every writer over at Vox is bad I'm
fairly good friends with a couple of
writers over at Vox actually but Dylan
Matthews is is just he's a first to your
econ student who should have failed he
says getting to Canada style health care
costs would require cutting doctor
salaries a lot 33 percent for primary
care 52 percent for ortho surgeons
that's fine they'll live but it's
important
to undersell the political difficulty no
it's not fine and this just demonstrates
the lack of understanding of how exactly
medicine works and he's citing a study
that shows that doctors in America are
paid significantly more than doctors in
other parts of the world it shows that
in Australia doctors make about half
what they make in the United States and
Germany they make about 70% in the UK
they make about 86 percent of what they
make in the United States the the
pre-tax earnings net of expenses in the
United States as of 2008 was about a
hundred and eighty six thousand dollars
for doctor
believe it or not that's actually not a
lot of money for a doctor the reason
that's not a lot of money for a doctor
is number one that is the average there
are a lot of doctors making below that
and a lot of doctors making above it if
you're a dermatologist you're probably
making half a million dollars a year if
you are a primary care physician there's
a good shot that you're making less than
186 thousand dollars a year depending on
where exactly you are practicing but if
you lower the amount of money forcibly
lower the amount of money that you are
that doctors are making do you think
more or fewer doctors are going to go
into the business of doctoring my wife
and I you know we paid our bills and we
had to spend on her college and medical
school education
we spent let's say four years of UCLA
plus four more years of medical school
so that would be a grand total of
somewhere in the neighborhood of three
hundred fifty thousand dollars three
hundred thousand dollars on her medical
education and then she had a three year
residency and in residency residents are
paid virtually nothing they're paid
basically less than minimum wage if you
actually average out the number of hours
they work to the salary that they make
which is very often like 50 grand then
you're actually averaging out to below
minimum wage numbers for people who have
been trained to take care of you if you
start cutting the salaries and she's not
gonna get to work until she's thirty
right she's actually none her birthday's
coming up I won't say how old my wife is
she wouldn't care actually if I did but
her birthday is coming up next week
happy birthday sweetheart if she once
she becomes a doctor she will be in her
30s and the fact is that she's already a
doctor but she won't be a practicing
doctor on her own until she's in her 30s
if you're gonna make up for all that
money you actually are going to have to
charge a lot of money in order to do it
if you want to lower the supply of
doctors all you have to do is forcibly
lower the amounts of money they can make
they'll live is not an answer to how you
provide more supply of medical care but
this just shows the ignorance with which
the Left treats got
intervention whether it's with regard to
Facebook or whether it is with regard to
the medical system okay meanwhile the
media have decided that they are the
heroes so the same people who say that
they are the heroes for having Alex
Jones banned from Facebook and YouTube
and they're theirs they think that bad
media ought to be banned they're very
very upset that the President of the
United States has called them the enemy
of the people and that he's mean to them
and that he gives them the SADS with a Z
at the end of the word its vid there
he's just very very means there's an
article over at CNN by a guy named
Joseph Holt he's an ethics professor at
the University of Notre Dame
Mendoza College of Business and this
article is so absurd it's almost hard to
describe the absurdity of this article
so here is what the article it is titled
the press isn't the enemy of the people
it's the protector not all heroes wear
capes folks they say it is a sad day for
democracy when the leader of the free
world repeatedly calls the press the
enemy of the people and as chief
spokeswoman can't bring herself to say
that isn't so yet that is what happened
Thursday at a White House press briefing
now again let me state for the 1 million
two hundred seventy three seventy three
thousand two hundred and nine time then
this is a bad thing the President of the
United States should not be calling
Americans the enemy of the people almost
they are legitimately engaged in
attempted terrorist acts or have a
allied with a foreign power but with
that said is the press over blowing all
of this it's over blowing all of this
because the press is very focused on
protecting itself they're not super
focused on protecting the American
people I love this and it says we thank
soldiers is how the article concludes we
thank soldiers for their service because
they devote themselves to protecting our
freedoms and we should but we should
also thank the media for the same reason
especially when the stakes have never
been higher if you actually believe
members of the press are like American
soldiers you are an agent you're an
agent
okay president Trump has directed
arrested zero journalists zero how many
journalists are in danger of being shot
every day in the United States the
answer is zero okay and if they are shot
at god forbid a place like happened in
virginia it had nothing to trump and
you'll see that there are members of the
press who keep trying to suggest that
President Trump is gonna be responsible
for the death of journalists there's no
evidence that has happened yet there's a
lot more evidence that Bernie Sanders is
responsible for the near death of
to Congress people then that Donald
Trump is responsible for the death of
journalists and yet you have folks like
Brett Stevens Brett Stevens is a real
never Trump RINO there are people who
use the term never Trump you just mean
somebody I don't like there are never
Trump errs are people who start saying
silly things simply because they don't
like Trump I mean people who are
conservatives or our conservatives who
say ridiculous things just because they
don't like President Trump so Brett
Stevens has become one of these people
even though I like a lot of what he has
to say this is really absurd max boot is
another we'll talk about him in just a
second Brett Stevens writes for the New
York Times and he says that if
journalists are shot there will be blood
on president Trump's hands I think we
are marching towards the day when
someone who thinks that he is taking
directions from the president and acting
in the best interests of the American
people against those of us presumptive
traitors around this table are someone
like that is gonna do that in a major
American news room when that happens mr.
president the blood will be on your hand
okay did anybody say this about the
President of the United States before
Donald Trump who was ripping on the
police day in and day out and then there
was a terrorist essentially he wasn't
shot a bunch of police officers in
Dallas I specifically wrote a column
saying Obama was not responsible for
that
he was responsible for an uptick of
anger against the police but he was not
responsible for somebody going and
shooting members of the police force and
yet now we have this sort of language
emanating from the media I find it
deeply depressing that there are so many
members of the media who seem intent on
treating the media as a separate class
from the rest of Americans and this is
what Americans are responding to the
media don't seem to care when Americans
are attacked on a regular basis by
politicians or when media members attack
regular Americans on a regular basis I
remember when Joe Wurzelbacher who was a
plumber in the 2008 election questioned
President Obama right he's then-senator
Obama about his plan to raise taxes and
Joe Wurzelbacher had the media dug
through his entire life they dug through
his entire life in media have used
inflammatory language about a variety of
figures both political and apolitical
and yet when it comes to the media being
attacked then all of a sudden the knives
come out listen again I don't think the
president should say this sort of stuff
but the media's defensiveness just
demonstrates that their real interest
lies in self-protection not in standing
up for the American people and this is a
serious problem this is why they're
still hosting people like Rosie
O'Donnell Rosie O'Donnell was on MSNBC
yesterday what does Rosie O'Donnell have
to say about anything
why is Rosie O'Donnell who has not been
relevant
generation even on TV she's there to
piss off Trump I mean it's the only
reason they're having her on here she is
he's a horrible horrible human with no
soul and he has a very serious mental
disorder there are so many psychiatrists
who were trying to get out the duty to
warn they wrote a book this guy is and
know being mentally stable enough to run
this country and he should be impeached
and every congressman who hasn't filed
those articles should lose their job
well I'm so glad that we have Rosie
O'Donnell to illuminate all of this for
us the media are just they're the
firefighters they're the soldiers
soldiers have on Rosie O'Donnell an
actual crazy person two rants about the
President of the United States that's
what actual soldiers do they are just
like the men and women on the front
lines who are battling the Taliban
that's what our journalists are like
according to that that idiot professor
from Notre Dame writing at cnn.com and
then they wonder why we think the media
are out of touch they wonder why we
think the media are out of such there we
think they're out of touch because it
turns out they're out of touch okay in
just a second I wanna talk more about
how out of touch the media are but first
let's talk about your watch okay do you
see this right here you see this
magnificent piece of hand jewelry you
see this right here on my wrist this
right here is a movement watch and it is
awesome I have two of them they are
great my wife has one my mom has one my
dad has one movement watches are great
and they are affordable as well movement
has come pretty far from being a bunch
of crowdfunding kids working out of a
living room in the past year they've not
only introduced a bunch of new watch
collections for men and women they've
also expanded to sunglasses in fashion
forward bracelets for her I've got a
pair of movement sunglasses well so does
my wife they are great movement watches
are all about looking good and keeping
it simple movement watch they're not
going to tell you how many steps you
took today or blow your wrist up with
text messages it tells time and it looks
good doing it and these watches start at
just 95 bucks at a department store for
watch this good-looking you're looking
at 400 500 bucks movement figured out by
selling online they could cut out the
middleman they don't have to up charge
and instead they're selling you quality
watches at a at a minimal price get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
shapiro c ymd mt keeps growing in mb mt
comm slash appear that's movement
watches go check them out MVM t comm
slash appear oh a lot of my fans already
have movement watches if you don't have
one you're missing out because they're
great go check it out MVM t comm slash
appear on get 15% off today ok speaking
of the media being out of touch the mean
seemed to be under this wild
misimpression that everything is racist
so max boot another actual never trumpet
right he's a guy who has decided
essentially that you should vote for
Democrats based on Donald Trump and
Brett Stevens did the same thing the way
that you can tell the real quote-unquote
never Trump errs from the people who
just didn't vote for Trump in 2016 but
didn't say that it was bad to vote for
Trump and who might vote for Trump in
2020 the way you can tell is whether
they are saying to vote for Democrats in
the 2018 elections so max boot says you
should vote for Democrats in the 2018
elections I believe Brett Stevenson said
the same thing if I'm not mistaken I
know that I know George Will has said
that as well
well max boot has an entire article out
today in The Washington Post of course
wearing his trademark journalist hat in
what she says right wing commentators
had a field day last week with the news
that sarah jong a young korean-american
hired to write about technology for the
new york times editorial board had a
history of attacking white people on
Twitter she was predictably pilloried as
a racist by the usual suspects and
understandably so as the post noted her
tweets and crew her tweets include oh
man it's kind of sick how much I enjoy
how much joy I get out of being cruel to
old white men in the New York Times
explanation that she had been countering
the trolling she received from races
online doesn't make much sense and he
basically says that the write is correct
about all of this is if John had been
targeting African Americans are Jews
there's little doubt her career would be
over as in fact happened with the
previous Times editorial board hire who
was quickly unhireable
with neo-nazi Ryan he's talking there
about Quinn Norton who actually long ago
had been friendly with a tech writer who
then turned into a Nazi and was fired by
the New York Times for once having been
friendly with that person so the write
has a point about John fine is max boot
but where are their voices when a far
more prominent bigot is spewing hatred
from a much more powerful platform
Friday night President Trump tweeted
LeBron James was just interviewed by the
dumbest man on television Don Lemon he
made LeBron look smart which isn't easy
to do okay let me just get this straight
according to max boot it is the same
thing to tweet canceled white people as
it is to tweet that LeBron James was
interviewed by a dumb guy Don Lemon
that's the same level of racism you know
far afield you have to go to reach that
conclusion now I'm not one who has
defended president Trump when I think
that he has said racially charged things
or even things that border on racism and
when he was defending the
Charlottesville marchers I was first in
line to condemn that because I
that was gross but to suggest that this
is racist when he says about LeBron
James LeBron James is is not smart or
Dom Lemon is not smart it's just
ridiculous and I love this max boots has
granted the very stable genius also
sometimes fuse charges of stupidity of
white men such as actor Robert De Niro
and James clapper but an inordinate
number of his attacks are directed
against women and minorities what
exactly is that supposed to mean can you
do it by percentage am I supposed to
direct a certain percentage of my
attacks against people of various races
based on the population of the United
States those 10% of my attacks on dumb
people can be in black people and then
70% have to be against white people and
some 15% have to be up against Hispanic
people 50% have to be against women 50%
have to be against men only 2% can be
against Jews really how is it supposed
to work I'm supposed to think before
every stupid before calling anyone
stupid I'm supposed to think about the
proportionality of the name-calling to
the population of the United States and
what in the world is max about even
talking about he says the kind of
prejudice Trump exhibits is far more
toxic and dangerous than Jung's remarks
in which he suggested the white people
should basically all die you're right
president from saying he doesn't like
LeBron James and he likes Michael Jordan
who happens to be wait for it a black
guy right that that's actually worse
than what Sarah Jong tweeted he says we
have a long ugly history of
discriminating against and visiting
violence upon African Americans Latinos
Native Americans and Asian Americans
black people were lynched whites
generally weren't though a Jew was once
Asians were barred from coming here
White's generally weren't and lo we have
made real progress toward a more
colorblind society we are not there yet
and with Trump at the wheel we are going
in Reverse there are too many videos
circulating online of police officers
harassing beating even killing African
Americans in situations where White's
would have walked away unmolested again
he's going to have to show the proof
that this is happening
disproportionately to black folks as
opposed to white folks based on race hey
there
there's a very famous case out here in
California homeless man named Kelly
Thomas people don't know it across the
nation because he's a white homeless
dude who's beat to death
by a bunch of cops this is far from
sympathizing with the victims Trump
attacks the African American NFL players
who protest police brutality very
clearly max boot thinks that Trump is a
worse guy than Sarah Zhang he says
there's a double standard on racism in
the country and liberals are guilty as
charged but conservatives are far worse
in their hypocrisy and their actions are
far more destructive
okay anybody who
the Conservatives are far worse on
racism I
there's an entire theory from the left
that racism is okay actually okay based
on the ethnic identity of the person who
is spewing the racism there's an entire
school of thought on the Left called the
intersectionality that suggests that we
can a judge how valuable your opinion is
based on your membership in a variety of
victim groups that is an actual tenet of
the Democratic Party now I may not like
how people have gone soft on president
Trump's horrible statements at times I
may think that's terrible but to pretend
that that is endemic to the Republican
Party in the same way that the
intersectional identity politics is
rooted in the Democratic Party is to
ignore the reality of the situation
Donald Trump is a figure who I don't
think has been good for racial tension
in America I don't but if Donald Trump
were to leave office tomorrow and Mike
Pence were to take over that pretty much
cured that particular problem
okay if a Democrat were to take over
tomorrow the problem would not only be
cured it would not only not be cured it
would be exacerbated in a pretty
significant way because the Democratic
Party has full-scale embraced the racist
rhetoric of Sarah Jean remember if a if
a Republican were to be caught saying
the same thing Sarah Jean we're saying
that person would be finished their
career would be over
the only person who's gotten away with
anything that I would say even remotely
resembles that stuff is Donald Trump in
his statements have not remotely
resembled with Sarah Jong actually said
if Sarah is wrong we're a Republican
she'd be out of a job right now she is
not she's on the Editorial Board of the
New York Times that should demonstrate
the institutional power arrangement that
allows the left to get away with their
racism it's so funny the left will say
that racism is prejudice plus power well
if you want to talk about prejudice plus
power you're gonna have to talk about
the left that combines its own prejudice
against various groups of people with
the belief that that power should be
enforced on behalf of those prejudices
that's an actual that that's a bigger
problem it is and they'll and the the
attempt to paint Donald Trump's Donald
Trump is a racist based on these
comments about LeBron James it's not
even remotely accurate that's the part
that's so crazy if you want to go after
Trump based on actual statements that
are racially tinged have at it but you
don't have to stretch to go there then a
second i'ma show you how far the left
stretches to go there because it really
is crazy but first I want to talk to you
about
investment strategy so Robin Hood it's
an investing app that lets you buy it
and sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos
all commission-free
it's an awesome awesome app yeah we've
been using the Robin Hood app here at
the office and there are there are a few
things that it does that other apps
won't do for you first of all their cost
structure is that there is no commission
fees other brokerages charge up to ten
bucks for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge commission fees they trade stocks
and keep that where you trade stocks and
then you and then they keep part of your
profits instead you are keeping all of
your profits every time you trade stocks
it's a non intimidating way for stock
market newcomers to invest for the first
time their interface is really easy you
can see the stocks that you have bought
and sold really really easily
they've easy to understand charts market
data you place a trade and just for taps
on your smartphone it's super simple
also they let you cultivate various
groups so you can have collections like
100 most popular and sectors like
entertainment and social media curated
categories like female CEOs so you can
pick whatever categories you want and
then cultivate your stock portfolio that
way and you can learn by doing an easy
way to learn how to trade is by using
the Robin Hood app you can discover new
stocks you can track your favorite
companies with a personalized news feed
and custom notifications right now Robin
Hood is giving my listeners a free stock
like Apple Ford or sprint to help build
your portfolio pretty awesome deal sign
up at Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm that
Shapiro my last name Shapiro dot Robin
Hood dot-com go check out the Robin Hood
app it is supremely simple to set up and
again their fee structure is great
because instead of them charging you per
trade they're charging you basically a
flat rate go check it out right now
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm again
Shapiro dot Robin Hood dot-com easiest
to use interface easiest way to trade go
check it out learn how trade it's a good
way to make money Shapiro dot Robin Hood
dot-com
totally worthwhile check out Robin Hood
okay so I'm gonna talk in a second about
the media's continuing attempt to move
beyond the bounds of rationality with
regard to the race issue but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire calm for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily we're calm when
you do rest of my show live rustic laven
show live rest of Knowles's show live
plus you get this with the annual
subscription the very greatest and
beverage vessels check this beauty out
this little beauty right here it's
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler my
goodness it does not lose half its value
once you walk off the lot instead it
just continues to accrue value based on
the number of tears with which you can
fill this particular temporal look go
get that with your annual
subscription $99 a year plus when you
subscribe over at youtube or at itunes
then you are updated with our Sunday
special I think what are we having on
this Sunday thing Tai Lopez is joining
us next Sunday for the Sunday special so
go check that out right now please
subscribe please hit the little bell
when you subscribe at YouTube so that
means that you are notified every time
we post a new video go check it out
right now we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
alright so the left has decided the
president Trump's comments about LeBron
James our full-scale racism while Sarah
Jones comments about white people being
canceled that's not actually racist
because she's Asian
which is weird also the left is really
gonna have to decide whether
asian-americans are privileged members
of American society or whether they are
discriminated victims in American
society Sarah John went to Berkeley inch
went to Harvard Law School
asian-americans earn more on average
than white Americans do by a pretty
significant margin and they are more
highly educated on average than white
Americans so which is it should we
discriminate against asian-americans in
in admissions decisions at Harvard or
should we label them victims of American
society capable of saying cancel white
people I'm gonna have to pick one local
leftist in any case Don Lemon says that
the real racist is President Trump
because President Trump has said mean
things about LeBron James this President
traffics in racism and is fueled by
bullying from keeping children at the
border in cages to bullying journalists
at every one of his rallies and every
chance he gets
okay so he you know he says this over
and over and over and over and again
linking this LeBron James is pretty
crazy democratic representative Tim Ryan
who wants to run for president based on
the yoga vote no I'm not kidding you
he's actually said this he's a
representative from Ohio in a swing
district and he says he doesn't want a
campaign on his blue collar credit
credentials instead he'd prefer to
prefer to campaign instead on the
so-called yoga vote yoga moms good luck
with that dude well he says that Donald
Trump is a racist because who's means a
LeBron James so again I don't think
LeBron James bad guy said this yesterday
I think he seems by all measures to be a
fairly good guy hey this guy who married
the mother of his children
I know it's a pretty low standard for
being good person in today's America but
he did I think he married the mom of his
kids which is a good thing he just found
at a charter school which is a very good
thing to do he's putting his own money
into it he helps out the community he
gives a lot of money to charity well
all that said saying that you don't like
LeBron James does not mean that you are
in fact a racist but according to
representative Ryan Donald Trump is a
racist because of what he had to say
about LeBron the president is being
racist there's no question about it I
mean come on
he's always got to find a black person
he's always got to find a brown person
that he's got a prop up and make fun of
to try to stimulate a certain portion of
constituents that he has a certain
following that he has okay so
I just want to point out here's a list
of the people that President Trump has
called low IQ or dumb Mika Brzezinski
quote-unquote dumb as a rock dumb as
rock by the way is his favorite it's his
favorite description of somebody he's
you searched his tweets he has used dumb
as a rock
about 1,000 times in his tweets here's a
just a partial listing of the people he
is called stupid Mika Brzezinski dumb as
a rock white person Katy - are
incompetent white person Jeb Bush dumb
as a rock just like mica white person
Lindsey Graham dumb mouthpiece white
person Glenn Beck dumb is rock Tom lemon
black person dumb as a rock Jennifer
Rubin untalented a real dummy low IQ
white person Chris steyr Walton Marc
Thiessen dumb puppets John Stuart not
very bright totally overrated Robert
DeNiro a very low IQ individual Stuart
Stevens dumb guy Bill Kristol dopey Rick
Wilson dumb as a rock
Sherri Jacobus dumb Bill Cosby foolish
stupid are getting bad advice Jonah
Goldberg dumb as a rock Rosie O'Donnell
crude rude obnoxious and dumb Bill Maher
stupid guy / bad ratings Chris Matthews
dumb as a rock and scores of others hey
the New York Times came up with a
listing in January 2016 of all the
people Trump had insulted online the
total number was 487 487 people he had
insulted individually online had like a
hundred and twenty thousand tweets I
really doubt that I have insulted that
many people directly on Twitter I mean
for Trump it's just a habit and I
haven't seen the racial breakdown I'd
like to see that is he really insulting
black people at like a 50% rate but the
idea that everything he has to the left
only has a few adjectives it likes to
use about people racists stupid vicious
so they try to use all of them on Trump
simultaneously not every comment Trump
makes is racist and when you say it to
people the Trump is a racist based on
the LeBron James statement all you're
doing is actually undermining your own
case this is where the media really do
themselves a disservice
these firefighters rush to the fire they
spend as much effort on Donald Trump
tweeting mean things about Don Lemon as
they do on the presidents of the United
States says something bad about trial
it's like legitimately the same effort
hey they are expending 100% effort all
the time it's it's not really bright you
shouldn't expend all of your all of your
energy in one place particularly that
place happens to be stupid
they meanwhile speaking of stupid the
water at the West Hollywood City Council
has now voted to recommend that Donald
Trump's star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame be removed now there
problems miss first of all his star on
the Walk of Fame is not actually in West
Hollywood so this has the same relevance
as Pyongyang deciding that the star of
fame should the star on the Walk of Fame
should actually be removed we drove past
the star on the Walk of Fame and the
other day and people were crowded around
it like it was the site of a killing now
it was pretty wild they had put up these
pylons to protect the broken star on the
Walk of Fame and now they have they have
passed a resolution here's what they say
this is mayor Jon's Iran he wrote West
Hollywood City Council unanimously
passed his resolution asking the
Hollywood Chamber of Commerce to remove
the Donald Trump star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame during a meeting mr. Duran
said the resolution is not because of
his conservative politics or his
conservative policies it is for the
abuse of women minorities immigrants the
disabled you've crossed a line of
decency okay so I would just like to ask
a question and the question I would like
to ask is whether in fact Hollywood is
filled with people who abused women
minorities immigrants and the disabled
the answer of course is yes okay I know
a lot of people in Hollywood let's just
put it this way if you're a woman in
Hollywood you have not been abused you
are in a minority the number of women in
Hollywood who have been abused by a
powerful man is extraordinarily high
because men in positions of power
particularly women who would like to be
a star when those men say get on that
couch I'm not hiring you a lot of women
will do that and it's terrible and it's
awful those guys all have stars on the
Walk of Fame
they all do it's a Harvey Weinstein
still has star on the Walk of Fame it
has not been removed Kevin Spacey he
still has his star on the Walk of Fame
the West Hollywood City Council doesn't
care about that they don't like Trump
because if Trump were on the left is
there any doubt that they would be
begging to put his star on the Walk of
Fame like they're still looking for an
excuse to put a Bill Clinton star on the
Walk of Fame even though he's never been
in a movie they're still looking for an
excuse to put a Hillary Clinton star on
the Walk of Fame being on the left or
being on the right is the only thing
that matters here but this is it the
good news is for the left I guess that
according to article 49 of the US
Constitution once you remove Donald
Trump's star from the Walk of Fame he's
no longer president of the United States
so that's very exciting stuff I think
that's what they're really attempting to
do here they're attempting to remove
Trump from the presidency through sheer
force of of rageface they're just gonna
make rageful faces at things and then
hopefully Trump will sort of dissipate
into the ether except of course that is
not actually going to happen by
rage can't help get-out-the-vote I mean
let's let's make clear that 2018 may not
be a good year for the presidents of the
United States may not could be a good
year for Trump it may not be a good year
for Republicans but if you think that
Democrats are gonna win power on the
basis of breaking Donald Trump star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame or shouting
racist at Trump repeatedly you haven't
been watching politics for the past
several years okay meanwhile the
Democrats are struggling for an
alternative vision and their their
alternative vision is basically Trump is
a traitor and let's be socialists and
I'm not really joking or exaggerating
about this Cynthia Nixon is seen as one
of these figures who is going to be the
future of the Democratic Party along
with Alexandra Ocasio Cortez boom got
her name right this time hey Alexander
Ocasio Cortez is the new face of the
Democratic Party despite the fact that
she knows no things okay all the things
she thinks she knows are things that are
not true she is okay I'm not saying this
because she's a woman or because of her
race she's a stupid person
okay Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is not a
bright egg now I'm saying this only
based on her public statements I do not
think that she's a good expositor of her
viewpoint there are many people on the
Left who agree with her who I think are
much better expositors of her particular
viewpoint I do not think that Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez is a wise spokeswoman I
think she's charismatic but charisma and
Bryant brains don't always come in the
same package and if you disagree with me
those of you on the left think about
what you think of President Trump the
fact is charisma and brains not exactly
the same thing in any case she's
considered the new face of the
Republican Party another person or the
Democratic Party another person
considered a rising star in the
Democratic Party is Cynthia Nixon who
you remember for playing one of the
Miranda is it on Sex in the City and
right the least popular member of the
Sex and the City crew you'll remember
her from that but now she is running
against Andrew Cuomo need the the living
block of wood who acts as New York's
governor she's running against him and
she's passionate about her agenda what
is her agenda well she spoke at Netroots
nation which actually should be called
nut roots nation I mean it's just where
everybody goes to be an insane person
Cory Booker shows up and he does his
weird jazz hands and talks about how
socialism is the way and then holds up a
sign saying America shouldn't have
borders and Israel shouldn't have
borders good luck with that Corey and
then Elizabeth Warren shows up to
basically announce she's running for
president good luck with that as well
and what you really need is a more a
more obnoxious version of Hillary
Clinton who claims she's a Native
American that's gonna work out great for
you Cynthia Nixon
though summed up the new
Democratic platform in one statement
here it is growing number of candidates
to identify as a Democratic Socialist if
being a Democratic Socialist means
believing that health care and housing
and education should be a human right
than I am a Democratic Socialist okay
and what she says is if the Republicans
are gonna call a socialist anyway maybe
we should be socialist first of all if
anybody ever uses the formulation if
being X means blah blah blah blah they
don't line to you because usually what
they're doing is they're saying if it's
like if me if being a communist means I
just love puppies then call me a
communist no that's that's not what
being a Democratic Socialist means okay
when you say that if you say that I
think that Democratic Socialist means
free health care no I think democratic
socialist means you want to nationalize
all major industries in the United
States and abolish the profit margin
which is what the Democratic Socialist
platform actually says I think being a
Democratic Socialist does not actually
mean that you want to just add a bunch
of redistributionist programs atop a
capitalist edifice that's not what your
program actually says because it
wouldn't be less popular if she went up
there and she said if being a Democratic
Socialist means nationalize all the
industries and put them under the direct
control of government for
redistributionist purposes thereby
killing profit motive and destroying
every major industry in the country and
I'm a Democratic Socialist she can't say
that because that's actually what
Democratic Socialist means so instead
she gets up there and she starts
shrieking about if I'm a democratic
being a Democratic Socialist means that
I like to kiss babies then that's me
okay yeah that's that if that's her
stick okay I guess that's your stick but
if the future of the Democratic Party is
just declaring the or Democratic
Socialist which means unicorns and
rainbow then I don't know to tell you
try running on that let's see how that
goes for you and if anybody on the right
has any capacity to debate they should
be able to knock the Democratic
Socialist arguments down with
legitimately the push of a finger it
really is that easy
the other program the Democrats are
pushing of course is the idea that Trump
is going to be removed from office via a
deus ex machina that Robert Muller will
swoop in like a Valkyrie aboard his
avenging horse and then you will take
out the President of the United States a
democratic representative named Cicely
I has come out now and says that it's
that David Cicilline from Rhode Island
he says that we can probably oust Trump
based on the the Trump rush of stuff
right now yeah good luck with that I
think there's enough evidence there
certainly to present this information to
a grand jury obviously mr. Muller and a
grand jury will make that determination
but on its face this is a prima facie
evidence of a conspiracy to violate a
campaign finance laws and with mr. Trump
juniors admissions of knowing the
purpose of this meeting based on those
emails I think he definitely has
liability
okay well let's find out whether that is
true or not but if you are placing all
of your faith in democratic socialism
and Donald Trump is a Russian agent I
would say the Democrats have to come up
with something better in the near future
maybe not for the congressional
elections but for 2020 for sure okay so
now it's time for some things I like and
some things I hate correct yes we are at
that point in the show let's do it okay
so the things I like I've started
watching big little lies with Reese
Witherspoon and Nicole Kidman and
shailene woodley and I have to admit
that I was kind of off put by the
marketing campaign for this particular
show because I felt like it was just
gonna be like a female gossip show
essentially not geared toward men at all
and it turns out that the show is
actually extraordinarily funny and
well-written and pretty great Reese
Witherspoon particularly is just awesome
and I've always underestimated Reese
Witherspoon as an actress honestly like
I've always not been super impressed by
her but she really shows ranger it was
she nominated for an Emmy for this she
should have been if she was not she's
just she's tremendous in the role Nicole
Kidman is quite good as well though I
find her character less believable
Shiley Woodley also shows her chops it's
a really really good cast and the
writing is really sharp about four
episodes in and I honestly it's an
addictive show it's a really really good
show here is here's some of what it
looks like are you new to Monterey yeah
we just moved here a few weeks ago
you're gonna love it you're so nice this
is Monterey we pound people with knives
to death
everybody wants to prove who's the
richest we're talking about viciously
competitive people and not the root of
it was Madeleine exactly how psychotic
do you think I am
he's a lot younger in Kirk Celeste she
must be pretty you know so bad we are so
bad
changes didn't fit here thought it was
nice for the nannies to get to know each
other it's it's so snippy and so and so
caustic and so wonderful and there are a
couple of there they're a bunch of great
performance isn't it like the cast is
universally quite good but I will say
the roots Witherspoon obviously has a
media stroll and she really does a lot
with it so go check it out obviously not
for the kiddies it's it's HBO which
means that for no reason at all they
just have to show breasts this is like
an HBO rule is that every show that
could easily be done without me showing
up the breasts must show the breasts so
that's this HBO is like if you're gonna
pay for a cable man and we're gonna show
you some boobs
that's it that's HBO's stick right Game
of Thrones would be exactly the same
show without showing the boobs which is
why it always used to be you know the
basic campaign on Game of Thrones was
that expert who's called sex position
right and whenever they would do
exposition they'd have somebody having
sex in the background so it's like if
you don't like what we're talking about
here's these two people doing it right
that's sort of how HBO does its business
but you put aside sort of the random sex
scenes there there's a couple that are
necessary but you put aside sort of the
random sex scenes and and the show is
really really good so go check it out
big little eyes okay time for a couple
of things that I hate okay so the
Russian embassy tweeted out yesterday
yesterday was the the the anniversary
the 73rd anniversary of the bombing of
Hiroshima
okay the bombing of Hiroshima was a
horrific event it was also generated by
the fact that the Japanese would not
surrender despite repeated attempts by
the United States to get them to
surrender
it was necessitated by the fact that a
full-scale invasion of Japanese islands
would have required the death of
probably a million people
it was necessitated by the fact that we
asked him to surrender over and over we
Lee flitted the town beforehand telling
people to get out and then we dropped
the a-bomb and within days the war was
over well the Russian Ministry the
Russia is the Russian government is just
garbage they're just it Putin is an evil
piece of human debris and the people who
work for him see
you know better well here is what they
tweeted out yesterday today marked
seventy-three years since the inhumane
and horrific a bombing of Hiroshima not
a military target but a city full of
civilians including women and children
first of all important to note the
single biggest group of people who were
actually killed in Hiroshima were
members of the military because the were
a lot of military members who were
stationed in Hiroshima August 6th 1945
will forever remain a tragic date in
human history such tragedy should never
be ignored or forgotten hashtag never
again says says the country that was
responsible for the gulags the death of
20 million people the Holodomor which is
the the forced starvation of forced
collectivization of ukraine ending with
the deaths of legitimately probably
three million people minimum when the
country responsible for the invasions
and murder of people in Hungary in
Czechoslovakia the building of the
Berlin Wall responsible for the backing
of the Vietcong in Vietnam responsible
for the backing of the Maoist regime
that ended with the murder of 40 million
people or so yeah talk to us about using
the a-bomb to end World War two by the
way also necessary to remember that
Russia was on the wrong side of this war
originally as you recall they were
responsible for the Molotov Ribbentrop
pact which was the treaty signed in 1938
between the Russians and the Nazis that
essentially led to World War two if the
Russians never sign that treaty the
chances that World War two breaks out
are significantly lower then Russia
switch sides and were all supposed to
pretend that Russia was grand in that
war Russia was fighting a preferred
survival because the Nazis turned on the
Russians it was not that the Russians
decided to attack the Nazis as the
opposite so and that's not to put down
the sacrifice of the Russians when it
came to fighting the Nazis but it
doesn't suggest the Russian government
run by Stalin was one of the most evil
governments on the face of the earth and
in human history probably the most evil
government on the face of the earth in
human history the only one that could
possibly challenge it really there are
couples there would be a couple that
would be up there right so Hitler would
be up there
Stalin might rank higher than Hitler
honestly I did and then a maybe above
him Ismail and Mao killed more people
and and Pol Pot would have to be up
there in Cambodia as well the Kim regime
would have to be up there in North Korea
in terms of evil regimes so Russians
you're gonna rip on us about our human
rights record you go after yourselves
okay you think you have no leg to stand
on here none and worth noting two days
after the United States dropped that a
bond on Hiroshima guess who entered the
war against the Japanese oh yeah
the Russians declared war on Japan two
days after the bombing of Hiroshima so
they're actually on the side of the
country that dropped the a-bomb so if
they really don't like it then maybe
they should have done that all right
other things that I hate so there's an
article that's just astonishingly great
in its stupidity from area from Marie
Claire as that has pronounced okay good
and it's it's all about how skinny
eyebrows are apparently problematic now
everything is problematic it's an
article by Christina Chavez says I'm
latina I find Rihanna's skinny brows
problematic Jess you're latina are
skinny eyebrows problematic okay
just as laughing and can yes no they are
not problematic because only stupid
people sit around thinking about whether
eyebrows are problematic first of all if
someone should know about problematic
eyebrows let's just say right here okay
check check these babies yeah I got
these ones right off the rack but here's
what the article says it says I got my
eyebrows threaded for the first time
when I was 12 years old as I walked out
of the salon and miring my new skinny
brows my mother stared at me they gave
you chola brows she gaff horrified
before immediately making me swear to
never thread them that thin again
because at the time and the
predominantly Mexican and Mexican
American city of Los Angeles pencil thin
brows weren't seen as a fashion
statement they were seen as a gang
affiliation marking you as a chola a
female gang member
suddenly I was the sixth grader with the
hugely polarizing gang sign on her face
a sign I had been raised to fiercely
avoid and have avoided ever since I'm so
confused so you're the racist right like
this seems like a trickle basically
saying the person writing it's the races
because she's the one who said her mom
is the one saying like if you get her
eyebrows threaded in a particular way
that it's because you're I wouldn't even
know how to I don't know Spanish so I
assume that's some sort of slur right
Chola it just help me out here
a female gang banger okay fine so when I
saw Rihanna on the cover of British
Vogue this week with the sin of ultra
skinny brows my immediate reaction was
wait WTF why is Rihanna wearing chola
brows considering it was highly unlikely
that Rihanna had suddenly joined a gang
and seeing as the Caribbean singer was
not exactly raised on the streets of
East LA my Mexican American heart was
deeply confused and deeply annoyed oh my
god
get a life hey go like go out look at
this hunt shrine make some friends get a
career or sit around and worry about
Rihanna's
eyebrows I think our society is too rich
okay I'm just gonna put it out there
maybe I'm if being a Democratic
Socialist means I think that society is
too rich and we are in the late stage of
capitalism then perhaps I am a
Democratic Socialist because if you have
the money to sit around worrying about
Rihanna's eyebrows on your day like in
the middle of a weekday if you don't
actually have a job requiring you to do
more than worry about how many hairs the
the hair count on Rihanna I'm just gonna
suggest that you need that you need to
find something better to do with your
life okay finally let's deconstruct
culture for just a moment so there's a
very controversial story out now about
Evangeline Lilly so Evangeline Lilly is
the star of ant-man and the wasp she was
originally she became famous originally
because she was in the show lost right
which was one of my favorite shows of
all time up to the point when they
completely destroyed the show in the
fifth and sixth seasons yeah they was
even through the fifth season it was
okay and then they ruined everything
yeah they ruined it season six damn you
Damon Lindelof damn Utah how in any case
one of the big problems supposedly that
happened on the set is that Evangeline
Lilly said in an interview that she was
made to feel cornered on the show's set
about doing partially nude scenes
creators and executive producers JJ
Abrams Damon Lindelof Jack bender and
Carlton Cuse issued a joint statement
apology for the alleged problems on the
show they said our response to Evie's
comments in the media was to immediately
reach out to her and to profoundly
apologize for the experience she
detailed while working on lost we have
not yet connected with her but remain
deeply and sincerely sorry no person
should ever feel unsafe at work period
so she claims that she was mortified and
trembling after filming a specific loss
scene she said in season three and had a
bad experience on set with basically
being cornered into doing a scene
partially naked and I felt I had no
choice in the matter and I was mortified
and I was trembling and when it finished
I was crying my eyes out and I had to go
on and do a very formidable very strong
scene thereafter and then she says in
season four another scene came up where
Kate was undressing and I fought very
hard to have that scene be under my
control and I failed to control it again
and so then I said that's it no more you
can write whatever you want I won't do
it I will never take off my shows my
clothes on this show again and I didn't
okay so I am confused by what like I'm
gonna need a more specific definition of
being cornered into doing a scene
partially naked did they like chained
her to the set did they threaten to fire
her did they threaten consequences
remember Evangeline Lilly was the
lead on this show right Matthew Fox was
the first lead and then Evangeline Lilly
was the second lead and is the idea
really here that if she'd said listen
I'm not doing that that they would have
forced her like they became her or they
would have suspended her from the set or
not or replaced her on the show she's
not making any of those allegations so
she's gonna have to be a little bit more
specific about what happened here also
I'm just gonna say I find it very very
difficult to believe maybe it's true in
her case maybe Evangeline Lilly is one
of the few infamous modest actresses in
Hollywood but Hollywood actresses
typically go into these roles knowing
that there is a chance that they are
going to have to take their clothes off
at a certain point and on the network
show we're not even talking about like
Evangeline Lilly showing her all right
it was a network show it's actually
against FCC standards for her to
actually get fully I mean this is what I
say HBO's app a cable channel so they
can get as nude as they want but you
don't actually see that on network
television by by most standards the
stuff that she different lost is pretty
mild for TV no am I saying she's being
dishonest here no I mean maybe that's
how she felt I am saying that the idea
that she was cornered into it I'm gonna
need to see some more evidence of that
before I come to the conclusion that she
was indeed cornered into it and again it
would be good to have listen I hope all
actresses hold by the standard that they
don't want to get nude on film I think
that the country would be a better place
if we had more of that so good for her
for saying she's not gonna do it anymore
I just find it difficult to believe that
a lot of Hollywood actresses actually
feel that way I don't think a lot of
Holly I mean we live in an era when
critics actually say that actresses are
brave for getting naked on film it's an
actual sign of bravery you're baring
your soul when you bare your breasts
it's sort of the idea I've always
thought that was idiotic I hope if
Evangeline Lilly agrees I'm on her side
but the immediate jump to she must have
been victimized on the set based on I
don't know is a little bit much for me
okay other other elements of the culture
to deconstruct so LeBron James
apparently now gonna create a series
called shut up and dribble in which he
is going to take advantage of the fact
that Laura Ingraham once said about him
that he ought to shut up and rebel he is
going to do this show on Showtime he's
going to serve as an executive producer
on a three-part documentary and it's
going to look at the changing role of
athletes in our front cultural and
political environment through the lens
of the NBA do I think that we actually
need more commentary from members of the
NBA about politics they can do what they
want
I mean it's free country say what you
want but I'm not gonna give extra
credibility to NBA players about matters
political simply because they're good at
a different skill set I don't think that
for example musicians have a skill set
that involves politics if I said you
know first of all there's this whole
idea that came out when Laura Ingraham
said shut up and dribble that she was
being racist about LeBron James really
she said about the Dixie Chicks or as
white as white can be shut up and sing
so it really has nothing to do with that
the conflation between celebrity and
skill sets that cross the boundaries of
celebrity is not good for the country
I don't think LeBron James is a
political expert because he's good at
basketball I think he does a lot of
wonderful charitable things but I'm not
gonna pretend that I think that he's an
expert on tax policy or financial policy
and I think that being sucked into the
realm of celebrities politician has not
worked out well for anyone involved as a
general rule okay well we'll be back
here tomorrow with all the latest
updates I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018